[Musica]
[Applauso]
made in italy
scienza e creatività due concetti che
dovrebbero essere agli antipodi che per
molti sono agli antipodi ma per me non è
così anzi secondo me è proprio ciò che
ha reso famosa in tutto il mondo
l'italia il made in italy e l'italian
motor valley dove siamo oggi il percorso
di creazione del made in italy e proprio
caratterizzato dai contrasti come il
fallimento e consacrazione e mezzo in
mezzo sacrifici tantissimi sacrifici
ostacoli da superare ma anche tanta
soddisfazione e non arrendersi mai
ma è veramente difficile spiegare cosa
sia il vero sacrificio ed è veramente
difficile anche spiegare cosa passa per
l'anticamera del cervello di un
imprenditore che vede cose che altri non
vedono cerca cose che altri non cercano
esente cose che altri non sentono
ma attenzione siamo tutti imprenditori
siamo tutti imprenditori ogni mattina
quando avendo delle responsabilità
prendiamo delle scelte dobbiamo prendere
delle decisioni
siamo imprenditori di noi stessi cose
semplici ho sempre pensato che per
spiegare con certi complessi fosse molto
utile fare delle dei parallelismi con
delle cose più semplici di tutti i
giorni mio padre usava questo metodo con
me quando da piccola mi spiegava le cose
più semplici e addirittura da grande mi
ha insegnato a gestire le sue aziende e
quindi questo il metodo che vorrei usare
oggi per questo abbiamo tre oggetti su
questo tavolo una tavola da kite un paio
di scarpette da punta e un casco da moto
sono tre oggetti che per tutti
significano quello che sono ma per me
significano molto di più significano
sacrifici ostacoli da superare ma anche
tanta passione insoddisfazione sapete
cos'è il kitesurf è uno sport velico
nato nel 1999 dove sia una vela in alto
che serve per catturare il vento che è
quello che ci spinge in avanti e poi
siano delle linee lunghe 24 metri
che sono collegato alla barra di comando
che si tiene in mano e piedi abbiamo una
tavola una tavola vi può essere una
tavola da surf monodirezionale oppure
una tavola come questa è nato in team è
una tavola per freestyle per per fare i
salti ma questa questa è la tecnica del
cai theron ed è molto di più
ho iniziato a fare kite quando avevo
trent'anni e mi ero stufata di stare
solo sulla spiaggia a guardare gli altri
e dire che bello come mi piacerebbe e
quindi ci ho provato
sapevo che sarebbe stato molto difficile
ma il kite non è uno sport del kite è un
assetto mentale uno stile di vita e
travolgente ed appassionante anzi tra di
noi scherziamo dicendo che è come una
droga che ti dà dipendenza
quando durante un viaggio a salo
conosciuto mito monteiro il campione del
mondo di kite non ho conosciuto solo
maestro di kite ma soprattutto un
maestro di vita perché emytoo è partito
dal nulla da sal una terra praticamente
sconosciuta e poverissima fino a poco
tempo fa e ha potuto contare solo su se
stesso sulla sua passione sulla sua
forza di volontà suo amore per la natura
per lo sport e ha scalato le vette del
mondo del mondo sportivo diventando
addirittura campione del mondo e
addirittura si impara inventato un uno
sport perché ha inventato la categoria
strapless share a tavola da sola senza
srap quindi mito mi ha insegnato che se
lui è riuscito a diventare campione del
mondo partendo dal sull io almeno poteva
imparare a divertirmi e ad essere una
cantera ma soprattutto mi ha insegnato
che cosa veramente mi affascinava del
kite lo sguardo guardare lontano
non vedrete mai un carter guardare sulla
spiaggia
lo vedrete sempre guardare lontano
guardare il cielo per cercare il vento e
l'acqua per cercare le onde e le maree e
e con questo sentirsi il libero
ed è questa la prima grande lezione per
fare impresa guardare oltre guardare
lontano e sentirsi libero tantissime
cadute tantissime sessioni negative ma
nel sempre valsa la pena perché la
sensazione di libertà che si prova nel
essere sospesi tra cielo e acqua è unica
e la forza della natura ti fa sentire
piccola però anche umile e in
contemporanea forte e ti fa sentire viva
e più umana e poi abbiamo delle
scarpette delle scarpette da punta
la danza è la mia seconda grande
passione ed è una disciplina che lascia
un forte una forte impronta in chi la
pratica anche in chi solo la provata una
volta la scarpetta è composta da tre
parti principali abbiamo una tomaia che
i soliti nel raso la parte esterna poi
abbiamo la punta la parte più rigida su
cui si appoggia la ballerina per
l'equilibrio e poi abbiamo la soletta
che è la parte che sostiene il piede ma
ancora una volta questa è la tecnica del
ballerino vede molto di più vede sogno
vede il palco vede la luce soffusa
mentre si aspetta lenta entrata
trionfale dell'etoile avete mai
conosciuto un danzatore sono conosciuti
come degli artisti dei professionisti
teatrali ma in realtà sono delle persone
estremamente testarde determinate che
non si lasciano abbattere da allenamenti
estenuanti cadute ma soprattutto dalla
ricerca spasmodica per la perfezione
perché la danza e questo non è uno sport
è una disciplina ed è rigore e la prima
sfida è con se stessi baryshnikov diceva
non cerco di ballare meglio di chiunque
altro
cerco solo di ballare meglio di me
stesso cadere credere per imparare a
rialzarsi rialzarsi
sempre da un punto di vista diverso in
un modo diverso coprirsi le ferite e non
accontentarsi mai
ed è questa la grande lezione della
danza la seconda d'elezione per fare
impresa rigore e tenacia due elementi
che non possono assolutamente mancare in
una persona che voglia intraprendere il
percorso di creazione d'impresa e non
solo da un essere insiti nella persona
dev'essere smisurati e purtroppo non si
imparano si hanno e poi abbiamo un casco
un casco da moto probabilmente quello
che mi identifica di più avete mai visto
avete mai visto veramente lo sguardo di
un pilota è proprio lo sguardo della
vita va dal fallimento alla
consacrazione
marco simoncelli diceva che si vive di
più andando 5 minuti al massimo su una
di queste moto su una moto da gara che
certa gente in una vita intera
eppure se guardiamo la la definizione
della enciclopedia treccani ci dice che
la moto è un telaio con un motore due
ruote
molti motociclisti si metterebbero a
ridere a questa definizione perché in
realtà sappiamo che una volta molto di
più però fino a poco tempo fa era
semplicemente un veicolo di trasporto
economico per chi non si poteva
permettere l'auto poi negli anni 60 70
diventata uno status symbol e oggi
quello che è quello che potete trovare
nei negozi e potete provare ai fans raid
è il frutto di un lavoro di squadra
incredibile che parte da un imprenditore
che ha visto ben oltre la definizione
dell'enciclopedia treccani e da un
ingegnere che non foglio bianco ha
trovato soluzioni a problemi
apparentemente impossibili e insieme
alla sua squadra da un foglio bianco ha
creato un progetto il progetto è
diventato un prototipo il prototipo per
anni e anni è stato testato è stato
testato a fatica è stato testato per la
certificazione per l'omologazione e poi
si fa la presentazione al mercato la
presentazione agli importatori dai
negozianti alla stampa e poi si prendono
le chiavi di quello che ormai ha
comunque
figlio se danno al cliente finale e poi
e poi si riparte da capo dal nulla al
tutto il processo di creazione
inspiegabile
l'idea è diventata una forma reale è
diventato un motore un telaio lo schizzo
su un foglio bianco è diventato una
carena vera e il pensiero si è fatto
prodotto è pronta e pronta la moto siamo
pronti abbiamo in pista il nostro pilota
questa
questo è il suo casco alessandro è
entusiasta come noi prendiamo la moto
andiamo in pista in esame i test e
iniziano i primi problemi
torniamo a casa vari progetti amo i
pezzi
ritorniamo in pista e ci sono altri
problemi e siamo caduti e ci siamo
rialzati perché come diceva enzo ferrari
la passione permette di sopportare
amarezze rinunce che l'ambizione non
giustificherebbe in alcun modo certo
il pilota corre per vincere se corre per
vincere però vincere non è il fine è
solo il punto di partenza perché in
realtà quando si vince se volete a
un'altra sfida la sfida si rigenera
sempre e l'imprenditore già pronto per
una nuova avventura sfida e passione
nascono dalla perfetta combinazione di
fallimento e consacrazione che rendono
l'imprenditore quello che è un sognatore
che non si è mai arreso avete mai
guardato per davvero un imprenditore
negli occhi non lo vedrete mai dietro
una scrivania o dietro uno schermo ma lo
vedrete sempre guardare fuori dalla
finestra aperta e pensare a un foglio di
carta bianco su cui scrivere la storia
oppure i muri i muri della sua azienda e
pensare quando prima era solamente
campania e poi fondamenta muri
macchinari persone prodotti innovazione
storia che cosa c'è dietro agli
imprenditori che cosa c'è dietro agli
imprenditori che hanno lasciato latte
nel nostro tempo da dove nasce la loro
passione con manufatto lasciare il segno
guardando lontano guardando oltre
vedendo cose che altri non vedono
trovando soluzioni a problemi
apparentemente impossibili e insieme al
proprio straf staff trasformare pensieri
idee in prodotti e cadute sacrificio
difficoltà passione tenacia cadere
fallire e ricominciare e poi
ricominciare daccapo perché perché così
ci sentiamo più vivi e più umani
grazie mille
[Applauso]